ulrike kriener wir haben in den letzten
tagen berichte gelesen und gehört in
denen donald trump als er gehört hat von
seiner infektion jedoch tatsächlich in
sorge war um seinen eigenen zustand und
tatsächlich gefragt haben soll
ob es ihm so ergehen könnte wie einem
freund einem new yorker freund der an
cholera gestorben ist was können sie uns
als jemand der den präsidenten sehr gut
kennt sagen über dem zu über den
mentalen zustand von donald trump in
diesen tagen wie geht er mit dieser
erkrankung um
wie ich schon vorhin gesagt habe der
präsident konzentriert sich darauf die
arbeit für das amerikanische volk zu
lassen er ist eine außerordentlich
robust führer und er hatte milde
symptome und ich denke man sollte jetzt
in der öffentlichkeit keine
informationen austauschen die einfach
nicht da sind wir sind alle überzeugt
dem präsidenten geht es sehr gut und was
um ihn herum geschieht ist das äußerste
vorsicht und sorgfalt angewandt wird um
ihn so zu überwachen so dass es zu
keiner änderung zum schlechteren kommt
tatsache ist viele menschen ziehen sich
kurve und es geht ihnen eigentlich nur
sie aber nur kleine grippesymptome
es gibt einen kleinen trotz einsatz von
infizierten denen es nicht so gut mit
vorsicht gebiete es also dass man den
präsidenten so überwachte er ist in
bester stürmer in typischer donald trump
ist der eben wirklich ganz heiß darauf
wieder zu arbeiten die ärzte sagen er
sollte vorsichtig sein